das besondere an dir ist ja dass du
wirklich im wahrsten sinne des wortes
einen gangster rapper bist da gibt es
sehr wenige fahren
du warst in der jva siegburg und anderen
unter anderem die berühmt berüchtigt
leider ist da gab es tote tote was ja
schrecklich ist aber du bist
andererseits auch einer der dann ich
sagen formuliert war so total integriert
worden ist ich sage es gab eine
schauspiel stück über dich also jemand
agenturszene integriert ist das bei dir
wirklich durch den gefängnis aus teilt
so eine 180 grad wendung gewesen oder
wie war das bei mir sagen ich war ja
nicht nur ein ich war öfter wir finden
uns auf jeden fall und die harmlose
sachen bildung einer kriminellen
vereinigung das ist schon das brett das
ist auf jeden fall ein dickes brett
gewesen natürlich der staatsanwalt
musste sehr lange
die anklageschrift vorlesen oder
erheblich wie soll ich sagen war auf der
schaden auf jeden fall erheblich und der
richter aber alle natürlich kennst du
doch was ist diesen jugendlichen mit so
eine kriminelle energie
das war für die sofort klar da muss man
wegsperren und so das wort gangster wut
ist ja in deutschland schon ein bisschen
ausgelutscht weil die leute denken
möchte selbst von mir alter ich habe
schon mitbekommen die leute sein und
möchte nur weil er denkt erst mal im
knast einen gangster nein das denke ich
nicht
er hatte aber nicht weil ich habe das
gemacht für das was ich für nötig
gehalten habe um leistung um meine
taschen voll zu kriegen
das habe ich nicht gemacht und meinem
nachbar oder irgendjemanden zu sagen hey
cool ich bin ja nie gemacht und diese
ganzen sachen zum beispiel im knast
nicht filmen lassen oder über darüber zu
retten was ich jetzt mache jetzt kann
ich machen weil ich meine strafe ist
abgesessen
zwar mache ich das nicht mehr und das
ist auch kein geheimnis mehr
das heißt sie land darüber öffentlich
reden ohne dass man sagt der rede über
diese sache aber macht das noch nicht
ich mache das nicht mehr
was soll ich sagen die klasse tiefer
cluster ob hier oder dort die erfüllt
das selbe ist das denn was gutes nein
auf gar keinen fall also das ist nicht
das was ich auf die ich sage mal gerade
spur wieder
also von der schiefen bahn in die spur
gebracht hat ich kann ja so nicht sagen
aber ich weiß nur dass ich durch die
ganzen sachen medien mäßig ist es mir
gedacht habe
lasst mich das erste mal machen ich weiß
noch genau ich gedacht habe ich habe nur
gedacht lass mich das erst mal machen
gucken wie erfolgreich sind kriminell
sein kann ich danach immer noch da ist
immer hier
die ist hier drinnen die allermeiste
kann man das sieht man ja wie legt man
nicht abnehmen ist verbrechen so was wie
sucht sucht ja wenn du von klein auf
verbrecher bis ich meine andere wollten
polizisten werden andauernd
feuerwehrsprecher
ich hab ja ich hab mich was ich wollte
ich hatte so ich weiß nicht ich wollte
sportler werden einerseits aber auch
irgendwie hat dieses verbrechen liegen
mich voll angezogen ich weiß nicht warum
ist leider früher so gewesen
ich bin nicht dass ich nicht stolz drauf
oder so aber ich sage halt not wie es
ist so ist es fakt so was kann ich auch
nicht verleugnet das ist immer ein teil
von mir zb ein messer so schwer wenn ich
nachts nach hause laufen irgendwo immer
die läden an
ich gucke ich bin voll so immer noch was
was was kann nicht holen
aber ich mache das nicht aber das ist es
schwer abzuwägen das ist voller kampf
mit mir selbst was kannst du hier holen
die camps ein laptop
das ist oder wenn ich essen gehe
ich guck direkt immer fluchtwege falls
mit einer falls etwas passiert ob nicht
legal war ich habe diesen aber bei
vielen leuten so das ist bei leuten die
kriminellen sind oder waren
wir haben immer noch diesen diesem
dieses denken so weiß vielleicht kann
das passieren da muss ich mich aus dem
staub machen
ich mach ja dass ich mache ja nicht
etwas was die mehrheit will was die die
leute wohl ich mache das was ich will ob
du willst auch du willst oder nicht
mache ich das was ich bin
lust auf wenn ich diesen bieter und
stellt mir da muss was die bis drauf
vielen dank